this horror film just got picked up
ahead of its Premiere at Fright Fest the
picture's premise is the urban legend
that a supernatural being from the
afterlife will violently murder anyone
who cheats on their partner I mean who
would be afraid of this I mean I know
morality play is something that we talk
about a lot in horror but like are we
really at the point where we have to
make a horror film to convince somebody
not to cheat are we really at this point
now obviously I love horror but one of
my pet peeves is having dumb characters
you can just already smell it with this
I mean I'm not trying to judge a movie
before I see it but you know there's
going to be a point in the movie where
the characters figure out why people are
being killed and all they have to do is
not cheat on their partner and they're
still gonna do it and like what is this
the entity or is this just someone in
the movie if this is the entity it
doesn't look that scary but let me know
what you think are you going to be
seeing cheat when it becomes available
are you going to be shaking in your
shoes at the supernatural being from the
afterlife fool violently murder anyone
who cheats on their partner or are you
just going to be seeing the movie to
root for the supernatural being from the
afterlife who will violently murder
anyone who cheats on their partner let
me know in the comments